en el último vídeo vimos cómo construir
un vector normal unitario a la
superficie y estaba dado por esta
fórmula que estoy marcando aquí este
vector n que esencialmente es la parcial
de r respecto de cruz la parcial de r
respecto de b entre la norma de este
mismo vector esta es el dividido entre
su norma es lo que nos hacía que fuera
unitario entonces lo que queremos hacer
en este vídeo es sustituir esta fórmula
en la integral original que de hecho ya
la volvía a copiar y estamos integrando
sobre la superficie y lo que quiero es
que veamos una forma de simplificar esto
un poco y podamos resolver esta integral
o bien de expresar esta misma integral
de varias formas según según algunas
aplicaciones que pudiéramos tener o
algunos autores que quieran darnos a
entender algunas cosas lo pueden
expresar de distintas formas entonces
vamos a tratar de abarcar unas varias
así que vamos a empezar el vídeo
justamente sustituyendo esto
el igual a la integral a la integral
sobre la sobre la superficie de f donde
f si se acuerdan es una función
vectorial es un campo vectorial ok y
vamos a multiplicar a m quien sn déjenme
hacerlo solo con blanco para para notar
darme tanto entonces esto va a ser r b
cruz r b todo esto lo dividimos entre la
norma de hereu cruz
rb la norma o la magnitud ok y ahora lo
que hay que hacer también es sustituir
de s quien desde ese bueno vimos en
vídeos anteriores cuando cuando
estábamos construyendo la integral de
superficie que de ese esencialmente es
el área es una área verdad es como el
área de un parche que se encuentra sobre
la superficie entonces como calcula
vamos es a esa área pues lo calculamos
como la magnitud o la norma de eeuu
rb ok y esto lo multiplicamos por dvd
que que aunque es notación lo podemos
interpretar como que son cambios muy
pequeños en el parámetro y en el
parámetro b ahora como ya estamos de
esta forma ya no estamos integrando
sobre la superficie ya ya ya la sobre lo
que estamos integrando es sobre beebe
entonces vive estarán definidos en el
plano recuerden que la superficie estaba
en en el espacio de tres dimensiones
vive están en el plano en la en el
espacio de dos dimensiones en alguna
región
r digamos ok entonces si eres bastante
listo y bastante abusado te darás cuenta
que esto ya se puede simplificar
bastante verdad porque porque tenemos la
misma magnitud de hereu cruz
rb en este denominador y aquí arriba
multiplicando este salida del factor de
quien era de s así que para simplificar
esto podemos simplemente quitar estos
dos numeritos
así que esto será la integral la
integral sobre nuestra región r donde
estén definidos los parámetros de f que
es nuestro campo vectorial punto y r
estos dos se cancelan verdad entonces
nos queda r 1 cruz r b
y esto lo integramos sobre las variables
y ve ok esta fórmula es la que usaremos
a menudo para calcular esta integral es
la más sencilla digamos para que podamos
calcular es lo que lo que signifique
esta integral de superficie ahora
esencialmente así vamos a calcular esto
es decir si tenemos una parametrización
r porque herrera la parametrización de
la superficie entonces podemos calcular
sus derivadas parciales hacer un
producto cruz y eso nos da un vector que
si hacemos producto punto o producto
escalar producto punto vamos a llamarle
con con el vector
efe que f es un campo vectorial o una
función vectorial esto nos va a dar un
número y eso ya lo podemos integrar
sobre beebe entonces lo que quiero ahora
ver es otra forma en que podríamos ver
esta misma integral y voy a empezar de
esta de esta expresión de aquí ok
hereu cruz r&b
por dv entonces vamos a vamos a expresar
esto por ejemplo tenemos hereu es la
parcial de r respecto de v
ok y estamos haciendo producto cruz con
la parcial de r respecto de be ok y todo
esto estamos multiplicando lo todo esto
por dv
dv ok entonces lo que lo que podemos ver
es que de wii debe esencialmente aunque
son notación podemos interpretarlos como
cambios pequeños en la variable v y en
la variable b entonces lo que voy a
hacer es recordar por ejemplo que pasa
cuando tengo la multiplicación de un
escalar lambda cuando multiplica a cruz
b ok a y b son dos vectores entonces
esto yo lo puedo expresar como lambda
es decir en la constante pueden meterse
con alguno de estos vectores
y después hacer el producto cruz con el
otro o bien puede meterse con el otro
vector verdad es decir que yo puede
expresar esto como a cruz lambda b
entonces voy a usar esta idea para que
debe vistos como numeritos yo sé que no
es formal esto que estoy haciendo es
quizás son son un poco esotéricas estas
matemáticas que estoy haciendo pero da
muy bien la idea de qué es lo que lo que
estamos viendo en una integral de
superficie entonces ésta dv
yo puedo meterlo con la parcial de r
respecto de qué y entonces tengo la
parcial de r respecto de v que
multiplica a de q
aunque y tengo esto y esto lo puedo
asociar ahora debe puede meterse con la
parcial de r respecto debe entonces voy
a tener la parcial de r
respecto de b que multiplica a debe ok
así es cómo puedo yo separar este
producto cruz ahora bien esto esto
esencialmente digamos
dv la parcial de r respecto de eeuu es
que tanto cambia el vector r al variar
el valor y entonces desde esta
perspectiva de eeuu es un cambio
infinitesimalmente pequeño la está
digamos este parcial de v es también un
cambio infinitesimal mente pequeño
entonces lo que yo puedo hacer e insisto
esto no es del todo formal pero pero se
vale es cancelar estos dos numeritos
cancelo estos dos iguala parcial debe
con debe porque esencialmente son los
mismos cambios
ok esencialmente son los mismos cambios
no es formal esto pero da mucha
intuición de a dónde vamos a llegar
entonces esto lo puede escribir como
déjenme bajar un poco
esto es digamos la diferencial vamos a
llamarlo así la diferencial de r en la
dirección y esto esto no es la derivada
parcial de r respecto de eeuu
simplemente es el cambio en r la
diferencial que hay en esta dirección y
vamos a hacer el producto cruz con la
diferencial de r en la dirección b ok
entonces esto se volvió simplemente otra
vez un producto cruz de dos vectores
entonces que que es lo que estamos
haciendo déjenme hacer un dibujito de
esto
vamos a ver
y digamos que tengo aquí mi superficie
ahí tengo una superficie vamos a
de esta forma que me pase un poco pero
no importa la idea es que quede claro
entonces cuando yo tengo aquí un punto
digamos me fijo en un punto constante
sobre la superficie quién es la
diferencial de herrera en la dirección
es decir vario tantito y vemos cómo
varía el vector el vector r entonces
esto me da un vector de esta forma ok
también tengo la diferencial de r
respecto de b entonces voy a tener
también un cambio en este vector en
alguna dirección correcto entonces
cuando yo estoy calculando el producto
cruz de dos vectores lo que yo obtengo
es un tercero que es ortogonal a ellos
verdad es decir que su ángulo con
respecto a los otros déjenme pintarlo
mejor
que tengo yo este tengo un ángulo de 90
grados entonces es ortogonal a los otros
dos pero esencialmente ahora déjenme lo
quito quiero quiero que nos fijemos en
otra cosa esto esto nos da un vector
normal normal a la superficie
a la superficie
pero además sabemos que el área del
producto cruz de estos dos vectores
esencialmente se perdón
la magnitud de este producto es el área
que definen estos dos vectores en un
paralelogramo que es esta área entonces
esto es su magnitud su magnitud
es igual
escribirlo así es igual
al área vamos a dejarlo así al área cual
área al área definida por el
paralelogramo entre estos dos vectores
entonces si nos damos cuenta
esto podría ser común de ese está de ese
cual es la única gran diferencia la gran
diferencia es que este de aquí es un
vector y de ese es un número es un área
entonces vamos a digamos a nombrarlo
como desee pero vector ok en donde de
ese vector significa justamente esto
estamos calculando un vector normal a la
superficie cuya magnitud es el área de
este pequeño parchecito definido por las
diferenciales entonces al final que es
lo que nos queda esto va a ser igual a
la integral
a la integral son son símbolos bastante
chistosos verdad muy elegantes sobre la
superficie de efe
perdón vamos a él el f lo tenía con
color rojo entonces esto es efe punto y
ahora de ese que es esta parte del
morado es d es la diferencia es que esto
es un vector y no es un número entonces
ya tenemos tres formas distintas de
escribir esta misma integral de
superficie que ya está esta es la última
que encontramos también tenemos esta que
es la que más nos va a servir para
calcular esencialmente la la integral y
también su expresión original que
teníamos ok cuál es la diferencia pues
realmente depende de lo que el autor
quiere hacer con cada uno de ellos bueno
aquí vamos a pararle y nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo